Most plants grow in the ground.
They begin as a seed.
The seed opens up to a budding plant.
Part of the seed grows up toward the warmth of the sun above the dirt.
Part of the seed grows down into the ground.
The part that grows mostly beneath the dirt is called the root of the plant.
The part that grows up above the ground is the stem of the plant...
...or the trunk of the tree.
Some tree roots are so big, you can see them growing above the ground.
The root absorbs or soaks up water and nutrients or food in the soil.
This water and food goes up into the stem or trunk of the tree...
...and out to the leaves, flowers and fruit.
Roots also grip the Earth and keep the plant from falling over.
Plants grow toward the sun because they need sunlight to live.
The leaves grow out from the plant to catch and use the sunlight and air...
...to produce more food for the plant.
A plant needs food and energy from the sun.